on today's show we're going to be
talking about intrusive thoughts for new
moms and how do we control those
harsh images that pop into our head
we're going to talk about a marriage
that feels like it's on its last rope
and we're going to be talking about
setting boundaries physical boundaries
between siblings
parents and everybody else stay tuned
hey what's up what's up this is john and
this is the dr
john dolone show a show about you
for you by you it's a live show where we
take your calls about your life your
relationships
what's going on in your heart in your
neighborhoods and your communities
reminding people that you are not alone
and that most people most of the time
are doing the best
that they can and real leaders unite
people real neighborhoods come together
when things get hard
real love looks like showing up when
it's messy and it's inconvenient
and on this show we talk about falling
in and out of love we talk about
infidelity scratching grinding
clawing towards hope and we may talk
about people who still
forward mass email chains or mass
text forwards that let me know if i
don't afford it to ten
other people i'm gonna have bad luck or
death or a terrible life or rocket
diarrhea forever and ever and ever amen
or whatever
it's ridiculous these are guilt chores
these are chores dude and when you
forward one of these
you're asking me to do an errand for you
to give your little
jesus quote or your little climate
change quote or your political
whatever it is and forward it to 20
people or your life will come to an end
here's the thing
it won't come to an end my life's just
fine when i hit delete
delete delete in fact my life keeps
getting better every time i hit delete
so before you hit forward on a thing
that's going to require me
to do chores for you just hit delete
that's it that's all i think about who
still affords mass emails anyway
right that's so 2012. but whatever's
going on
let's do it give me a call at
eight four 1-844-693-3291-1845 six nine
three three two nine one or email me at
ask
john ramsey solutions.com we're getting
emails from
all over planet earth it's exciting it's
humbling
super rad and it's super weird man
but email me ask john john
ramseysolutions.com let's go straight to
the phone let's go to taylor
in tyler texas taylor and tyler how are
we doing
hey john i'm doing good how are you so
so good so what's up how can i help
um so i had a baby in march and i was
just wondering
how do i overcome the scary thoughts of
something
bad happening to him you had a baby
in march uh oh so i'm gonna answer your
question but i wanna back up
i'm remembering in march
i remember in march i was in downtown
manhattan
as like literally me and my buddy ken
coleman and a couple other guys were
walking down manhattan then down
broadway
when they came out of broadway like
where they had the plays and they said
all plays are canceled until further
notice
and people were scattering from the
street and then the next morning
i'll never forget being with dave ramsey
and a few other folks and we turned the
corner and
it looked like an apocalypse movie and i
remember thinking
like i've been waiting for the
apocalypse for years i've been training
for it forever
and i remember going oh this is not what
i thought
so it freaked me out is all i'm saying
and so
when i back out and think if i was
having a baby in march
dude i would probably still be
underground right now
put me in your mindset you realize
the world starts just shutting down like
a series of dominoes falling
january february and then march and then
oh look we're having a baby so walk me
through
that in tyler texas what was that like
oh
it was pretty crazy so i worked in
healthcare um so i worked in the
hospital yeah
so i work in the hospital but um it was
absolutely insane thankfully i was able
to have my husband there
and so it was towards the end of march
and so no family or visitors
um but it was really crazy it sort of
seemed like an apocalypse you walked out
and no one was there
so can we just for the listeners because
i have
a lot of my friend community is in some
sort of
medical area whether a doctor or whether
they are professors who live in that
in the healthcare space and you may have
experienced this too especially being in
tyler texas
where there were probably big swaths of
your world of your
community that this whole thing was a
giant scam
and then you're also watching people
come into the hospital every day and
you're like this is super not a scam
but then i also had doctors that were
like this is the most overblown thing
ever
and then i had other buddies of mine who
were doctors who were like hey listen
we're all gonna die
and i remember thinking i don't know
what you know what i mean like the
smartest people i knew
were looking at all the same data and
really the same patients and they were
coming with totally different things
did you experience that same thing oh
yeah my husband was
the one of the people that were like
this is overblown it's not
real and then here i am having to follow
all these
precautions and going to people's homes
or rooms
with like a full-on hazmat suit and it's
just like
what's happening and by the way let's
bring a human into this right so that
brings us to this call
so since you've had a baby so how many
months is that is about eight months now
seven eight months yeah he just yeah
seven months like last week okay
so you have had scary thoughts
intrusive thoughts what i call the the
night terrors for new moms
tell me about what your what what
thoughts you have
well um so because of covet anytime he
coughs i instantly think he has copied
correct
and um so i think that's like crazy to
think about because
we take every precaution we can but also
things that like there was a situation
here that happened
with a girl i knew she actually
got arrested for this whole thing with
that happened with a baby
and i can't stop thinking about how that
could have been
my son or something like that if i see a
car wreck
i'll think oh my gosh what if that was
us and then
i just picture him you know not
being here yeah yeah and those
do those thoughts they stay with you
do they wake you up at night or when you
wake up in the morning are they did they
shoot into your head in an otherwise
beautiful east texas day like
when do these thoughts hit you um
it's more when i'm not around him
um so like whenever i'm at work
and i think about that kind of stuff or
it's usually at night
when i wake up in the morning it doesn't
wake me up at night um
but like putting him down to bed or like
sort of the evening time
gotcha okay so i want to give you
hopefully a lot of peace and then give
you a couple of
things you can do okay okay so you work
in health care right
yes sir for folks who don't call me sir
i'm like
oh sorry 14 years old oh yeah look at
that texan it makes my heart feel good
my son told somebody yesterday the other
day and they're like you're from texas
and he's like
yes sir and then it just got funnier so
yeah i got you good for you
so if you're listening to this by the
way i know i talk about texas too much
get over yourself
but say yes sir and yes ma'am the whole
world will just be a little bit nicer
and wave at crosswalks together taylor
yes
me and you're gonna save the world all
right so you work in healthcare
and for those of you who have been
living under a rock underneath
the dirt for the last eight or nine
months
i want to put you inside of a healthcare
world right now
it is absolute chaos there are
economic issues because of the
cancellations of elective surgeries and
then bringing them back but not
there are some gut-wrenching
gut-wrenching
ethical and moral decisions being made
like people being forced to die alone
and family has to stay outside and what
we don't think about when those happen
we see those things on instagram or on
facebook about the stories of the dads
in the parking lot waving to their kids
we forget that there are nurses and
doctors
and custodial staff that are sitting
with those people
all alone as they are ill as they are
recovering as they are dying
and that takes pieces of your soul piece
by piece by piece
and so the first thing i want to do
taylor is this
i want you to recognize that your bell
curve has shifted
meaning you are living in an environment
that
outside of that environment is is
makes puts you in two different worlds
right it's not like you're going to be a
welder
and you're hanging out with welding
people and you all are doing welding
things then you're going home to reg
you are in basically a war zone every
day
and that begins to alter your sense of
what is normal and what is reality
okay two the next thing i'm going to say
is
everyone's going to get covered because
100 percent of the people you deal with
every day
might get coveted right right and then
you go home and you hear one sniffle
you're like that's it
because all day you've heard that and
you've seen it and so
all that is is your brain trying to
protect you it's all good
just remember not in the hospital and
remember like
we've made jokes about it um and it's
not like that's how i cope with stuff
and so it's not always
right or good and so don't send me mean
cards and letters everybody but
um the way it is now like if somebody
hurts their ankle it's like i probably
got covered
right or they you know uh they sneeze
yeah you got covered someone's like man
i worked out really hard last night now
my arms are sore covered right whatever
it is
so what what that what's happening i
want you to know it's totally
totally normal okay so you're in a
highly stressed environment that isn't
normal
and your brain is carrying that home
with you just think to your mind
thanks dude like you're trying to take
care of me and i appreciate that
the second thing is for new moms
um it is i've read
an argument that i buy that sounds
plausible that there is actually an
evolutionary component to
scary thoughts about your kid so if
you're pushing a stroller
and you all of a sudden you're walking
along and you're pushing your kid down
the sidewalk and there's a hill
and you think oh gosh if i let this go
he'd roll away down the hill and then
your heart
drops as though you did let him go and
he does
fall down that hill you're actually
going to grip that stroller tighter
right you are actually going to drive a
little bit safer
you're going to be a little more careful
when he's eating and so
one of the arguments i read is that
there's an evolutionary response that
that your brain wants moms to be hyper
vigilant to the point that they are
imagining scenarios
that could come true so that they make
sure they don't
all that to say whether that's true or
not you are in
normal company to be having these dark
thoughts especially if these dark
thoughts are new to you
some of us just go through life with
dark thoughts and this is just another
thing
some folks this knocks for a loop
because they feel like they're going
crazy
like why do i keep crazy yeah why do i
keep having this in my head
so i want you to know you're totally
totally normal where it becomes
difficult is when you start judging
yourself
when you start thinking i'm broken or
i'm a bad mom
or i must be psychotic because i had
this
image of my son or my daughter doing x
and then all of a sudden why happening
and i want you to give yourself some
grace and some peace on that
okay and so we're gonna do an exercise
that i do all the time with folks
um and i want you to practice it okay
i want you to close your eyes and in
fact we just did this in another show
recently and we're gonna do it again i
think we can do this for the next 30
years
and i got this from um the grief master
david kessler
i want you to close your eyes right now
and everybody listening to it if you've
already done it with me before do it
again
close your eyes and this time i want you
to picture a giant
um yellow banana on your front front
lawn
okay you got it sitting there and i
wanted to have a little red hat on top
of the stem part
okay okay you got it pictured in your
head
yes sir and your husband he's pretty
awesome
oh yeah okay i want him um i want you to
imagine him leaning up against this
banana in your front yard
okay okay now open your eyes
now what you have just done you taylor
have just proven to all of
the really the world there's a lot of
people listening to this all across the
world
you've proven to the world that you can
control your thoughts
you can control the images that are in
your head and so where these intrusive
thoughts
that that pop in like lightning bolts
they pop
in and then your body reacts to them
at that moment is when you get to choose
whether you're going to follow through
with
all the way to the end where your son
ends up in some traumatic situation
in the thought experiment right or some
your daughter ends up in some
really evil hard situation or you can
say
nope and then you can choose to imagine
a picture of your son riding on his
tricycle or you can choose a picture of
your daughter
at her wedding someday or whatever
fantasy you want to concoct about your
kids
but that is something you can practice
and then in short order
your brain starts to reset itself
because it does not get the bang for its
buck that it's looking for
and it's i call it changing your default
settings so it begins to default to
whenever you think about your kid
you can literally train your mind to
where a positive image pops in instead
of
the worst case scenario or as i think
it's martin seligman says
optimism is a learned behavior it's a
choice
and it is hard to do especially when
it's 5 a.m and that thought pops in your
head or it's 10 o'clock at night you
worked a full shift
and you picked up a couple hours of
somebody else's shift because they
didn't come in
and then you race home and you and your
husband are busy and you put your kid
down and then bam there it is
he's laying in the crib sleeping and
then it just creeps over you like a like
a
warm blanket right and then you go all
the way to the end of that thing
that's when you can stop and you can
remember
your dad holding him for the first time
you can put that picture in your head
and it's going to be a fight in your
mind for a while until you get the
strength to do that
and then there's one last thing i want
you to
to think about okay okay
you've had a baby and you now have a
tangible living breathing
example of your heart beating outside
your chest is one of my favorite quotes
and when you see your heart beating
outside of your chest
with these little hands and these little
eyes and this
little mouth and these little feet you
get to
really ingest the word risk
and true love is risk right
it's this idea that it might not always
go right
and it probably won't always go right
and you work in a world
that is there for when it doesn't go
right and so you are extra sensitive to
risk
and i want you to love that little kid
recklessly
in spite of that risk i think i could do
that
i know you can i know you can right um
and i said this was the last thing
final final thing often um and there's
some
literature out there some of these
thoughts can
increase if somebody's alone or they
don't have good social support
so make sure you have folks in your life
that aren't your mom and dad that aren't
your husband
that are friends that you can text that
you can call
that you have a constant stream of three
or four people you can text who've got
already had kids and they're gonna
answer is this normal is this normal
they're gonna go yep yep
or hey are you having weird thoughts
nope you should probably go see
you know you should go see somebody
because we haven't had that right um
but you need people in your life that
can tell you that's weird that's weird
but not you're crazy
right okay or if you are crazy that
you need to go talk to somebody we're
gonna go with you to talk to somebody
right
yeah but make sure you've got close
people in your life but you are normal
you are a great mom you are a gift to
your community
you are serving as a healthcare
professional in
a mess
and i'm so grateful that you're one of
the people
in our communities that are raising good
kids
taking care of the least of these being
a great partner to your husband
and trying to do it right and so
work on controlling those thoughts work
on not beating yourself up when
something dark comes into your mind and
recognize your mind just trying to take
care of you and trying to make sure you
take care of that baby
and don't beat yourself up and don't
judge yourself for it good for you good
for you
awesome awesome all right let's go to
paula in
h tone texas what's up paula
hi doctor how are you i'm so good
how are you i've been better let me just
kind of tell you what's going on
let's do it bring it on what's going on
having problems in my marriage
um i'm 52 okay i've been married for
about six and a half years
both of our second marriages we've been
arguing
like constantly probably for the last
six weeks
probably just calmed down last week
what are you arguing about so
it's mainly about my dog
he hates my dog and he he doesn't want
me to get rid of him he says
but he's been threatening lately he said
he's gonna take him to the spca
he doesn't want to get rid of him he
just wants him dead and gone so yeah
cool
exactly and that's like the main one of
the main things and we don't have deep
conversations
about the marriage about finances and
good times and bad times but
like the pet has really been uh
just coming up constantly and so i told
him i said
is the dog sorry i said um go ahead go
ahead
and i just told him i said if you do
that take him to the spca
what do you think's gonna happen to our
marriage
and he just said well you'll get over it
oh he called your bluff yeah
i was really yeah i was just
like okay so is this
is this these fights about this dog
is this dog a proxy war for
a marriage that's not communicating that
is not having
um good connection that's not
having lots of good um
intimate moments that is not um fully on
the same page with your finances and
with where you guys want to go as a
couple
is the dog just where all this is
landing
or does your husband just hate dogs
i think he hates this dog because
initially i've had the dog 10 years
okay i was not going to keep it he long
story short he was
he my sister wanted him she was living
with me and i said you need to take him
when you go but she couldn't and
i just decided to keep him and that was
before mary and after we got married he
thought i would get that adult a dog and
i said no
i'm not going to do that so
what keeps two grown adults
from going to have breakfast somewhere
you can even go to dinner for this
conversation
and saying we've got to deal with the
dog i don't like that the dog pees
everywhere i don't like the dog's hairs
everywhere i don't
like it's it sounds like um
sounds like two kids throwing crayons at
each other
and that's made me agree but you're one
of those kids and so what is it about
like the adult part well he just refuse
to engage you as an adult
or is he saying i want to be an adult
and this dog is whatever getting hair
all over my clothes or we don't have
enough money to keep
feeding this dog or this dog reminds me
you got him with your last husband and i
don't like you
importing parts of your last life into
this new life i want to start fresh with
my new wife
i don't want to here's what i'm saying
uh paula i don't want to
over dramatize this it might just be
like i
do not like cats i think cats are evil
and i think cats are one of the worst
animals ever created
and i know that people are going to send
mean mean emails to me about cats cats
are perfect
they're not they're gross creatures
there's no reason to have a cat
um and i know just send all the mean
letters everybody
but my wife knows that too
and so i've been honest with her she's
not a cat fan either but she's
indifferent about them if i felt like i
really needed a cat we'd have a cat
um they make my eyes itch but we have
grown up talks about it
and so i don't want to over dramatize
this in just because if my wife came in
with three cats tomorrow and she's like
hey by the way we're having cats i'd
have a problem with it because it'd make
me sick
i don't i don't i wouldn't like it i
don't want to spend money on that et
cetera
and so is it that or like i say is this
is there something else with your
marriage because if you can't have a
civil
conversation in marriage 2 at 50 years
old
about a dog my gut tells me there's
something else going on
i think there is something else i
recently found out
and this was because he didn't admit it
to me
i think there's been some type of abuse
as a child
okay that he experienced yes okay
and uh and i said well do you want
to talk about and he was just like no no
sure
so well here's the thing
abuse is hard and it's hard to talk
about
it's hard to experience especially if
you're older and it's kind of woven into
the
your patterns but with you which you
interact with the world
and i also understand it can feel like
someone's holding back from you or not
being honest with you or not talking
about things with you
when you find out that someone you love
has had trauma in their life and they
don't want to talk about it it feels
personal
like they're they're holding out on you
and so i want you to not think of trauma
that way
i want you to not think of his responses
that way
and instead i want you to create a space
where he feels
loved and he feels valued
and that he feels like
you're all in with him and those things
create an environment or an atmosphere
where at some point he may feel
comfortable speaking those things out
into existence
and it's less about holding back from
you but for some folks
especially older men when they start
talking about historical
trauma abuse as a child
they are waking dragons that they don't
have the tools to slay
they don't have the relationships they
don't have other men in their lives
they're going to sit with them and hug
them while they weep
uncontrollably they don't know how to go
to counseling or they've been told for
20 years that
or 30 years or 40 years people who go to
counseling are wimps and broken weirdos
they don't have church resources or
worse church says
just pray it away and it goes away just
get over yourself
if you really believed in fill in the
blank then you'd get over it
right and so it is less about him
holding out on you
and more about man if he opens that box
he feels like he's gone drowned and that
is a wound that has been there since he
was a little kid
and that is a wound that can only be
healed with um
an environment where he feels safe safe
safe
and if you're fighting over a dog that's
not there's something else going on
there
right if you're thinking about my
marriage is in trouble i think was what
you said
uh man there are bigger things at play
here
and so would he go see somebody would he
go talk to somebody and go see a
counselor
uh i suggested marriage counseling he
doesn't believe in
it uh talking to the phone okay well i'm
sorry i
suggested marriage counseling and he
does not believe in that okay
um and i will suggest that he talks to a
counselor but i don't
i don't know if he would go okay can you
go take care of the things
because you're you're a part of this too
you're with him too
you said i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
do this again i'm gonna get married
again and
um i'm gonna go all in on you i went all
in on somebody else before
it didn't work out i'm going all in on
you again and
i'm not gonna lose this over a dog right
right he also is going to say i don't
want to lose this because of the dog
right so you get this weird impasse
but at some point i want you to work on
you so would
you be interested in going to see
somebody to
talk about ways that you can communicate
with somebody who may have experienced
trauma
that you can be somebody who can diffuse
what sounds like a middle school
argument over a pet
right right and at the end of the day
all you can control is you
and at some point my hope is that you
begin to model for him
here's what communication looks like
here's what de-escalation looks like
like if he's about to pick a fight with
you you can say hey i love you i'm not
gonna fight with you over this
i'm gonna go for a walk i love you more
than life itself but
we're not gonna do it no we're not gonna
fight over this this isn't worth our
marriage this isn't worth our friendship
um and you're gonna learn some skills on
how to connect with somebody and maybe
they're skills you didn't pick up the
first time when you were married there
may skills that
that you haven't ever learned right but
at the end of the day that's all you can
focus on
are you worth investing in paula
yes i believe so i think you are i think
everybody
is worth investing in but especially you
and my hope is
that you learn some skills that you can
begin
begin to shift the kind of partner you
are and create an ecosystem for him
where he feels safe and connected to
it's not fully your responsibility to
heal him you can't do that
but as a partner of somebody that you
love you can help create an environment
where he can feel safe
and loved and connected and those are
three words that a lot of dudes don't
use
safe loved and connected they use
achieved tough and snap into a slim jim
yeah let's lift weights
let's play fantasy football where we use
other grown men as little figurines
let's do that yeah you're going to
create a context where he feels safe
and loved and connected and then at that
point he might be able to heal
and then this dog dude this just sounds
like a red herring to me it just sounds
like a distraction from
a couple that needs to sit down and say
we love each other let's figure this out
and i'm going to work on me and i hope
you'll work on you all right let's go to
taylor
in boston what's up taylor
hey john how are you doing i'm doing
outstanding what is up in boston
massachusetts how can i help you
um not much um basically it's just a
simple question
go for it let's do it so my brother
i love him dearly um he
probably doesn't always think that i do
um
he i guess he sort of craves
physical affection okay um and so he's
always wanted me to hug him or
want to give me a hug before bed or
before i go off to work before he goes
off to work
and sometimes i am just not in the mood
and so i try to push him away say like
you don't need to
always hug me whatever um
and he sort of takes it personal to be
honest he'll get mad at me
sure so i don't know so how old are you
i'm 21 21 how old your brother
20 20. so have you
always had a
a awkward physical relationship with him
do you not like it when he hugs you
because he
hugs you inappropriately he violates
your physical boundaries or you just
don't want to hug him
um probably mix a booth it's just like
i don't know okay um
so here's here's the the brass tacks of
it
you control your body and you
are um entitled to
and responsible for setting your
boundaries
whatever they may be and you are allowed
to have them
you are fully encouraged to have them
and i want to proclaim for you
permission to speak them on the you
don't need my permission you're endowed
by those
by god himself you are allowed to speak
those boundaries into the universe
and you're allowed to demand that other
people respect those physical boundaries
whether that's your dad your mom your
brother
anybody okay yep
what what is really helpful is
clear boundaries meaning
when somebody comes in to hug you and
you go ah
then you are maintaining your boundaries
you have a right to do that
but it's become a social issue too
if you go to your brother and one one
day before night time
and say hey from this point forward
we're not hugging anymore
we are high-fiving each other with two
high-five hands
and i'm not going to give you a hug
anymore or we're just going to side hug
one arm side hug that's it that's the
brother
hug then yep he can get over it
and if he chooses to throw a temper
tantrum that's his immaturity
not yours okay and so what i would
recommend that you do is be very
vocal and very direct about what your
boundaries are
here is what i will accept when it comes
to physical touch in my home
with my brother period end of story
and then he can get over that and you
can tell them i love you
i love you a lot these are my physical
boundaries
with my son my wife like my son is uh
freakishly tall like like a huge
and so at a young age he would go hug
women
and he would put his head right between
their chest like right in their chest
and it was uncomfortable for people and
he was
like four or five and six and he was
huge and he would nuzzle up
and it would make you get to see people
going like oh gosh and so my wife like
we had a hard straight talk with him
about these are private parts when you
hug somebody
you will shake their hand and if you
want to give them a hug you will side
hug them
and he even had a funny response he's
like but i like my head there i mean it
was he was just a sweet little boy
um he even said once i don't know if i'm
allowed to say this james he was like
but can i just put it between like and
we're like nope nope dude you can't do
that right
um but he was just a sweet kid wanting
to hug
he didn't have any there was nothing
sexual about it there was nothing he
just wanted to
be connected and it took us some very
direct these are private parts
these are not for you and um you will
hug me like this
and you will shake hands to strangers
and that's where it's going to be and he
adapted and he got it
and so i want to fully 100
tailor empower you whatever your
boundaries are physically
own them be proud about them don't
apologize for them and speak them out
into the world so that other people
know unequivocally what they are is that
cool
and yeah and i feel like part of it is
probably he he sort of went through a
rough breakup a while back and
it's sort of been ever since then that
he's been
a little bit more i guess wanting to
he probably just craved some sort of
affection sure
and affection's good violating
somebody's boundaries is not
and your job as his sister is not to
meet his need for
physical touch not to meet his need his
longing for intimacy
that's not a sister's job a sister's job
is to love their little brother
right a brother's job is to love his
brother right
um that's not that's not their job
and so it might be that you can hold his
hand hold his hand tight
and with both of your hands and make
sure he feels loved you can put your
head
on his shoulder you can put his head on
your shoulder
you can lock elbows with him you can
side hug the heck out of him
but you get to decide here's my
boundaries
and i'm not comfortable with anything
other than that and you can be very
forthright with them
okay and that is not a mark on you and i
know i've said it over and over in this
call i want everyone to hear that over
and over and over
everyone gets to own the autonomy of
their body and
the more that people feel comfortable
saying i am comfortable with this level
of interaction
i'm not comfortable with this the more
empowered they feel and the more people
can honor them with hospitality when
they come into contact with him
he may not know he may just think you're
being an annoying sister he may not
realize
um you are violating being violated
right
yeah right and so i want to tell you
i'm proud of you for setting boundaries
and i'm proud of you for
trying to honor him at the same time own
your body
good for you thank you good for you
um i'm really grateful for that call all
right so as we wrap up today's show
man we're gonna do it james james is not
a fan he does not think this is one of
the greatest songs ever
i disagree every once in a while not
often james is super wrong
this is one of those times it's from the
1998 classic
on how life is
the beautiful and super talented macy
gray
came onto the scene everyone in there is
going ah
you're all wrong wrong wrong it's taking
so much willpower not to turn your
microphone off
james just said he's trying so hard
enough to turn my microphone off
she came out with a song while i was in
college
called i try i try and she writes
games changes and fears when will they
go from here when will they stop
i believe that fate has brought us here
and we should be together babe
but we're not i play it off but i'm
dreaming of you
i'll keep my cool but i'm fainting i try
to say goodbye and i choke i try to walk
away and i stumble
though i try to hide it it's clear my
world crumbles when you are not near
listen to that james goodbye and i choke
i try to walk away and i stumble
though i tried to hide it it's clear my
world crumbles when you are not here
whoa macy my world crumbles when you are
not here people
this has been the dr john daloni show